what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine season five episode
one today it's two-parter but we're only
watching part one deal with it live with
it suffer in it leave a like while
you're at it too that would mean a lot
as always full and threat to watch Longs
releasing with your own copy Brooklyn
nine nine available for our super saxade
Rejects at our patreon page we've
covered several stuff exclusively over
there with reaction highlights and watch
dogs
let's watch the show
[Music]
just eating butter like a popsicle
humble yeah I know I'm spoiling myself
Jake my best friend is in prison wait
Jake's in prison yeah he and Rosa were
praying for a bunch of bank robberies by
Lieutenant Hawkins all right come on
Scully we were all at our baby shower
last week okay then why am I bleeding oh
I'm bleeding because my piece of crap
son-in-law bit me
whoa there has to be some way to
exonerate them I've been looking but I
can't find anything and I don't know
what to do I can't find anything and I
don't know what to do what
they caught Hawkins trying to flee the
country she confessed to everything and
they let me out
no it's baby but first I gotta hug my
best friend okay I just heard from the
mayor to apologize for what happened to
you they're sending you to Disney World
you and one male guests
were you dreaming about Jake again why
did you wake me up I told you never to
wake me
wake me up oh he's gonna say what a
shoot nobody give those I just got up
off I've been going for a second there
good morning Caleb
Tim Meadows it's visiting day
[Music]
revisiting day I think Jake would have
more enemies in here is where he on her
way it's Miguel happy visiting Andy hung
himself oh
she is Miguel what's going on with your
hair well it turned white from this
dress so I dyed it back to my normal
color with a splash of a tally do you
like it
how's my case going
oh I'm in protective custody because
everyone in gem pop hates cops I'm not
really sure why something about us
locking them in cages and letting the
world pass them by
haven't had any chance to make new
friends my soulmate Caleb is okay just
remember if he's in prison and no matter
how small the crime people don't change
and don't deserve Second Chances oh
trust me all I've been thinking about is
when you guys are gonna get down here
and now you are and we can finally talk
there's a incident in the yard we're
going in a lockdown inmates line up holy
you guys brought Hitchcock we don't
know why he's here Jenny baby I love
what prison's doing to your figure
I hate seeing you like this so I'm
flexing my eyes real hard to keep from
crying oh pay no attention to him Rosa
he's very emotional Rosa why are you
saying my first name wow Rosa
you need to be reminded that you're more
than just a number Rosa you are Rosa
Rosa
anything you need done on the outside no
I'm good it's not a problem Rosa we're
here for you Rosa Rosa
my family hasn't been to see me since my
trial you eat nine people and all of a
sudden they don't know who you are
anymore what a bunch of are you
a cannibal Caleb well that's not how I
would Define myself I would say that I'm
a woodworker
I did all my stuff and more there's tons
they can't even Trace to me the secret
is eating the evidence sure
if you really want to talk to people on
the outside just get a cell phone yeah
that'd be great there's this guy in gen
pop Romero he can smuggle anything into
this place let's find this Romero guy
right now I really want to chop down on
this meat
Club
Caleb hello Sarah what brings you to the
fence today just here to stab you if you
get too close
Caleb remind me not to stand too close
to the fence will do oh here's Romero oh
no Diamond Phillips ldp phone's a
hundred hundred dollars that's no
problem I've got no use for cash 100
cigarettes I want 100 soups you can't
smoke anymore so Ramen is replace
cigarettes I thought they sold Ramen at
the prison commissary I don't want
commissary soups you stupid little
boy I want flavors you can only get on
the outside chili lime shrimp
southwestern chicken straight flavors
look at that spicy stuff a hundred Ramen
first she wants us to move all her
furniture into storage really and then
she wants us to type up an email these
letters to pimento in Argentina nice
she's worried about her motorcycle
sitting idle so she wants us to take it
out once a day here
oh yeah motorcycles are death machines I
have three kids I'm not risking it my
life matters less because I don't
conform to society's heteronormative
child-centric ideals are you really
playing the gay card right now yes Queen
yes
Tara get another kid investigating a big
time money launderer under the table
because the brass got involved so there
were a lot of eyes on the operation
[Music]
well it sounds like it was a very
successful operation oh
hey hey hey here you go bro soup of the
day
great oh my God here's your cell phone
thank you oh by the way someone who's
eating a lot of ramen in his life here's
a tip leave a few noodles uncooked and
then sprinkle them on top afterwards
like a garnish
gives you an extra little fun bonus
crunch
that's gonna be your key I can't believe
I'm hearing your voice I know it's so
amazing and now every day can be like
visiting day and we can just talk about
whatever or whatever
oh I found them doing a sweep of
your bunks this is Toby Huss think out
another Picante beef is a street flavor
I was being kind to you by putting you
doing protective custody but if you're
going to bring Contraband into my prison
and flaunt my rules you're going to
genpop
what are we gonna do you're a psychopath
you can protect us in there right I mean
you killed and ate a bunch of people
they were children Jake weak little
children oh no
oh that's my bike great it actually was
a lot of fun to ride once I got the hang
of it
oh geez and you were able to finish
everything on my list wasn't too much
was it if anything you didn't ask enough
of us great because I thought of a few
more things oh my God yes yes he wrote
the number eight
equal sign equal sign equal sign equal
sign equal sign equal sign equal sign
capital d i what was the D
some people use the carrot
hello you're gonna die in here cop
sounds like Michael Rooker they hate you
so much they don't even care about me
yeah congratulations
I think I'm gonna need to join a gang oh
they're all watching them yeah I once
took a seminar on how to Ace job
interviews I'm really good at them this
I've got to see hey everyone I'm Jake
thank you so much
I can make a shiv out of anything I am
deceptively athletic I'm not sure if
your gang likes to play b-ball out in
the yard but I can dunk okay
please
what do you guys called again Isis oh
cool well I'm excited to join
Isis
geez remember that guy Romero who you
got the cell phone from if you got in
good with his crew nobody would dare
touch you but he is real scary and crazy
okay and how anti-semitic is he average
let's do it do you know how long I've
been in this prison
not once in all of that time have I ever
seen anything as disrespectful as uh
telling me how to eat my soups
[Laughter]
damn
crumbling the noodle on top gives it an
extra little crispity snap that was
blown away wasn't that tank hasn't
stopped talking about it oh snap come
here beef baby nobody can touch you now
wow I guess all it took was the ramen
tip actually you gotta do one more thing
for me to kill someone I need you to
kill a guard
okay great
babies out for blood
whoa It's Gonna be too hard it's good
you're gonna kill Wilson all right
rather not know his name it's Alan
Wilson he's got a three-year-old Dexter
they call him decks cool
instead of killing Wilson we get him
fired but that's not how we usually do
things around here sure but you know
what else you didn't used to do around
here sprinkle on good noodles on top of
your own yeah
we'll try your way
you're right you're right you've earned
the benefit of the doubt
it tastes hilarious yeah whenever the
bulls attack us the security cameras are
conveniently not working that day so I
have my own camera so you painted my
apartment walls and white wisps
and you picked up my abuela at the
airport yes I went and got her at the
Philadelphia International Airport oh no
I need you to cancel my cable
that's easy I've been on the phone for
six hours
when he attacks me you film it then
afterwards we'll meet up in the bathroom
what are you gonna do to get them angry
well I don't know I'm so I'm not sure
what buttons to push but I'm sure if I
try enough things something will set him
off oh you're gonna become his best
friend send me back to your table yeah
you know I would except for whoa oh my
God
show me the video I'll send it to
Charleston so you got it anonymously and
then
oh dude
I'm not good with new technology if you
want somebody to lure a kid to a park
using a lycos chat room I'm your man oh
button and make it front facing come on
let's try it again hey Wilson
no he's covering the lens
you added the fiesta filter I'm doing
the best I can tell that to my wiener
I'm doing no don't really gosh
wow okay
and I got everything I even zoomed in
for some close-ups thank God I was so
sure that something was going to go
wrong hey there Peralta oh no oh I'll
take that phone now son of a damn
you Dale Gribble I was ordered by this
guy Romero I don't know his first name
Jeff really Romero's first name is Jeff
yeah but I convinced him to let your guy
live if I got him fired instead why do
you want him to lose his job he's a good
man with a family I mean he needed stomp
on my head a bunch of times those were
warning stops
I'll fire Wilson really
why Romero's responsible for most of the
illegal stuff that goes on in this
prison I've always wanted a man on the
inside oh the only people less
popular in here than cops are snitches
let's be honest it's not great in here
for Trans people that is so true
a hard time a problem
sure
it's true
I hate to say this but you are asking
too much of us
is that how you feel too Sarge
yeah Rosa damn
here I'm low I'm a little scared I just
want to be back home and I was happy you
guys were coming to visit but then you
started calling me by my first name and
you kept making that crazy crying face
the only one that is acting like himself
is Hitchcock you oh yeah I need normal
interactions so I need you guys to fight
with me and be honest with me and tell
me no when I'm being unreasonable that's
ridiculous you're never gonna believe
this I've been reading by real authors I
don't know Philip Roth a real author oh
my goodness
I wish you had gone to prison years ago
so you go Wilson fired nice work welcome
aboard thank you I promise you you won't
regret it
oh if you screw me over I will cut your
testicles off and watch you bleed to
death in the dirt you got that oh boy oh
can I trust you yeah oh I'm your beef
baby
oh boy Jake that sounded really bad is
everything okay yeah everything's fine
I'm talking to you
not a doctor
interesting cut off point
I didn't know Lou Diamond Phillips was
so damn funny right I knew it could be
intimidating I knew it could be scary
and you could be dramatic I did not know
he was that funny there was something in
his filmography that I missed and
probably most of his filmography because
I can't really recall anything about Lou
Diamond Phillips other than I know who
Lou Diamond Phillips is
was he in Blade Runner I don't think so
he was not a player
I'm thinking of a different actor who
looks like Lou Diamond Phillips Susan
Blade Runner who's probably maybe star
some big biopic that was in prison right
well he did was he in like La Bamba he
was La Bamba yeah it was La Bamba in
prison
maybe I don't know do you sell his soul
for blues what has Lou Diamond Phillips
done before he was in that cowboy
western movie
Blade Runner Young Guns or something I
don't know yes he was
it's funny I've seen Lou Diamond
Phillips in like guest spots but never
like a Lou Diamond Phillips movie
yeah yeah that was great and Tim Meadows
with his earnestness he's got that
brilliant Earnest comedy oh sure not
Earnest like as in Earnest goes to
prison
Earnest yay sure and Toby Huss character
actor extraordinaire as the uh the
prison Warden good uh good casting there
as well a lot of guests that is a tough
pickle to be in even though I feel like
I I could easily survive prison you got
that dude you you lift oh no dude I
would just pleasure people sure I mean
that's also a way to get around I would
just do it good excuse yeah well this is
you know a little limber up your game
and then when you come back out you can
use that in all kinds of ways that is a
tense situation it seems like they've
made no Headway at all on how to get
them out of prison at all yeah first
they were fugitives I mean after if they
were uh witness protection now they're
in jail that's tough we didn't say any
of rose's lifestyle no not not a single
moment of it except for at the visit
that's surprising
but yeah that pressure to kind of have
to appease when someone's in a situation
like that my God I would just not visit
ing yeah yeah yeah yeah just charge it
man you know too much too much effort
let time heal that wound yeah yeah okay
I gotta be bothered I don't blame you
I've had so many friends go to prison
they're still there oh yeah yeah
I've even testified against them keep
them there longer
I don't want to deal with it yeah I mean
they know it's nothing personal you said
so on the stands I was gonna hear about
prison all the time now oh my God every
day
[Music]
and there's corruption throughout the
system same conversation all the time I
get so sick of it Bill let's talk about
the next Marvel movie yeah oh you don't
know what Marvel is you've been in
prison for too long you only had one TV
channel for 10 minutes a day so
frustrating so frustrating
so yeah guys
um I would survive prison John would
more than likely survive prison I I
would be useful in prison I would come
out a changed man but I would be very
useful to a lot of uh you know people
looking for something soft who does the
tattoos in prison
you know there's gotta be like a
particular inmate who just is really
good at it who becomes like the guy
because people get like prison tattoos
and I'm like illegal
I mean yeah probably to have something
that could give you a tattoo that'd be
illegal yeah I mean you'd have to make
it like a stick and poke you'd have to
use like a pen or some kind of like yeah
like file down paper Clipper so I don't
know how stick and poke works but it
seems like it would be Contraband at the
very least but I love Andy Samberg and
Tim Meadows together this cannibal
character is so funny
because I just love how he plays it like
such a child in a way that you have no
idea you you he doesn't play up the
criminal side at all
I love it yeah it's so well done it's
exactly how Tim Meadows would do it he
has such a a unique way of being Tim
Meadows he does like because he can he
can get big but I like that like so
often when he shows up in these bit
parts or guest appearances he does have
that like really Charming way of of
almost throwing all of the lines away
and never making too much out of
anything so he just has this like
unassuming sort of uh benign personality
but he still plays a character yeah
every time yeah it's always a little
different it's like he's not
transforming but he's still playing a
character he doesn't like fully go one
way but it's like just enough I I love
him I think Tim Meadows is one of uh the
most overlooked I mean like you know I
know he's famous and everything but I
feel like he should be more famous I
think is pretty overlooked yeah he
should have his own Eddie Murphy kind of
movie where he plays 10 characters that
would be fine why not you just put him
in that corner because he's black way to
go that's right man that's what you've
done that's what I do
category people together like they do in
prison I've never had to cancel cable
before Oh get ready one day you'll get
cable and then cancel it I don't have
any regular channels I don't have any
channels I mean now more than ever you
you there's like an app for that so
you're okay you missed the window
although the benefit of getting cable is
that you get all like the apps
you know like every channel you get you
can just log into the app with your
cable so it might save you money or it
might break you even
yeah he is probably but you know what do
you think of like HBO Showtime all these
other things
you know you maybe don't get Hulu but
fair enough all right well that's just
part one we gotta wait to see how part
two concludes because that's where the
real meat and potatoes comes into place
where the nitty and the gritty come to
play this is a tense situation I do like
it when they can keep that sense that
tension up and running because this
could have really easily just been a
bunch of sketches and goofball stuff but
there is a there is a tense situation
for him to be in because Prison is about
Survival Man people die in person they
show a lot of people die in prison for
various reasons I like it when they do
yeah like a little bit of a of a
slightly more intense storyline I feel
like it makes everything a little more
vital yeah yeah so hopefully they'll
stay in prison the whole season
um I don't know how they're gonna get I
feel like Jake could be in prison the
whole season
I think that would be fun I'm for it how
would you get out of this situation
I don't know I mean how do you do it
from the inside especially you need some
kind of Smoking Gun on Gina Gershon and
uh and so far nothing and we got no
further in this episode to that in
particular
although maybe the next episode we'll
see more of rose's time in prison and
then we'll see Boyle and Amy maybe solve
the case or something who knows John who
knows no one no one knows no one knows
alrighty guys well thank you for being
here
and uh we will see you all soon for a
more in-depth discussion on next week's
follow-up episode peace out reading